okay
okay
thank you everybody i'm just about to
read out the decision for the
tens application the crafty casks in
raleigh
the committee has given careful
consideration to the application
and all of the written and verbal
evidence presented including the
objection notice from environmental
health
the committee was mindful of the fact
that the concerns that had been
expressed by environmental health around
live music had been allayed
given the applicant's confirmation that
the only music to be played would be
recorded music set at a level of 70
decibels
in addition the applicant volunteered to
suspend any off sales of alcohol at 23
300 hours
the applicants also confirmed that
doorstop on duty and that these would
monitor noise levels and also ensure
that patrons dispersed appropriately
from the premises
the committee considered that applying
all the current conditions on the
premises license together with the
suspension of off sales at 23 1300 hours
and the employment of door staff at the
premises during the event would serve to
promote the licensing objectives
for this reason the committee does not
consider that account counter notice
would assist in promoting the licensing
objective
of prevention of public nuisance and
therefore consider that the lines for
licensable activities as stated in the
notice should be allowed with the
proviso that of sales of alcohol would
cease at 23.30
hours and the assurance of the applicant
that there would be no live music played
and that door staff would be employed
and that all conditions on the premises
license would be applied
this contin
concludes the hearing